[Music]
rapt mosque and Cana dies right here you
look like a woman
who's looking for some mostly fresh
animal parts I don't know
Celia usually buys whatever I have and
mr. piket seemed real interested so I
thought maybe I was onto something mr.
Pickett
Franklin Pickett from Edgewater that's
him he'd been here years but he always
talked about going back to Edgewater one
day sure mr. Pickett used to run the
community center outside Edgewater
he had this grand idea to make it a
museum for he'll see in life as my dad
told it mr. Pickett was always going on
about getting a man to Queen for the
last display he left the veil gosh years
ago he came to steller Bay years ago
just before the board cut us off ended
up stuck here it was always real
interested in our monsters mantle Queens
especially sure they're real big hard to
miss him well I could send you to the
same place I sent mr. Pickett but I
haven't seen him in a few weeks to tell
true I'm starting to get a bit worried
about him captain can we look for him I
feel awful if somebody from home was in
trouble and we didn't do nothing
tell you what I'll tell you where I sent
mr. Pickett if you promise to look for
him help him out if he's got himself in
trouble fair deal
[Music]
thanks captain all right then leave town
through the southern gate the one right
here and head past the abandoned ruins
last mana Queen I saw was in the wilds
out that aways could be mr. piket still
out there too
[Music]
ma'am please I need your help
[Music]
Oh smells like those old Sundays when we
download smell tuna shipments again am I
the only one getting hungry
[Music]
[Music]
even y again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this McDevitt used to say that plants
need sulfur to growing it is just tubs
of it lying about this is why I prefer
spaceship
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
service
[Music]
he'll probably be wanting it back you
see any sign of him funny place to leave
a journal but what about mr. Pickett
that's pretty sad he sure seemed like he
knew what he was doing he used to tell
the kids crazy stories about Halcyon
wildlife later I learned most of it was
wrong but it was the thought that
counted then one day he just disappeared
never heard anything about him again
so this journal is all he left behind
seems like I have to read it looks
mighty long though
you did always want to see one huh
that's a fine way of putting it in any
case I appreciate you tracking down mr.
piket for me here's some bits for your
trouble
[Music]
[Music]
you